I've told you before about some of the
astroturfing campaigns and sort of
disinformation PR campaigns that we've
seen around industries and products and
services one classic example is
cigarettes where the tobacco lobby
funded outreach to restaurants telling
them that if smoking is banned in bars
and restaurants it's taking away their
freedom it's going to hurt their
business and it was a really successful
way to co-opt restaurant owners into
trying to prevent the ban on indoor
smoking another example is the sugar
industry and the junk food industry
where every time that a study during the
60s 70s 80s would come out saying hey
you know a calorie is not a calorie
necessarily calories from refined sugars
are worse than calories from from other
food sources the sugar and junk food
industries would put out studies where
they wouldn't straight-up lie and say
there's no negative health impact from
having a lot of calories from sugar but
they would basically say you know it's
not really clear that the source of
calories is going to have an impact on
health a hundredths or a hundred
calories from an avocado is the same as
a hundred calories done by eating
spoonfuls of sugar which by the way
wouldn't be many many spoonfuls at all
so we've seen this over time let's talk
about marijuana and the disinformation
campaign that we are now seeing you know
because I've told you that many states
have ballot initiatives this November
8th this election day on legalizing
marijuana including here in
Massachusetts I've made clear I'm going
to vote in favor of that now opponents
of this ballot initiative in
Massachusetts have come up with a new
absolutely ridiculous ad campaign which
basically hits every anti legalization
talking point in 30 seconds it's called
neighborhoods it focuses on a mother and
daughter driving past a comical number
of marijuana dispensaries on route to
their local toy store and of course in
the commercial the
toy store is also next to yet another
marijuana dispensary and then a
voiceover warns that there's just going
to be so many dispensaries that are
going to be selling edibles that look
like candy etc etc let's take a look at
the ad let's listen to the ad and as
ridiculous as the ad is what's even more
insane is who is funding this ad that
after we look at it question four would
allow thousands of pot shops and
marijuana operators throughout
Massachusetts in neighborhoods like
yours shops that sell pot edibles that
look like candy and high potency
marijuana in pro pot states incidents of
drugged driving and fatal car accidents
are on more pot shops and McDonald's and
Starbucks combined higher potency
dangerous drivers
it's the reason health professionals are
urging them to vote no on four think
about the sick irony here the group
behind the ad is the campaign for a safe
and healthy Massachusetts the group's
biggest donors come from the state's
largest distributors of alcohol wine and
spirit wholesalers of Massachusetts
incorporated and beer distributors of
Massachusetts incorporated gave
seventy-five thousand dollars to this
group a bunch of local bars donated
thousands more to oppose question for
the legalization of marijuana according
to the Massachusetts office of campaign
and political finance alcohol is
responsible for an insane number of
fatal car accidents and alcohol unlike
how marijuana would be if legalized
isn't sold only at alcohol only stores
you can get alcohol at supermarkets you
can get alcohol at convenience stores
and get it almost everywhere and edibles
look like candy you know there's a laugh
a lot of apple juice Pat that looks like
alcohol to me and it's being sold at
Whole Foods and this ads seems to
portray things that are just patently
false I mean I'm not gonna be able to
drive around smoking and the kid that
comes out at the end looks like he's
like 15 16 years old I mean this is some
real reefer madness
it's absolutely right up and and alcohol
sold at grocery stores where kids are
allowed and what Pat is alluding to is
that marijuana will only be available at
dispensaries where you have to be 21 or
over to even be allowed in and by the
way the entire ad other than being
funded by the alcohol industry is filled
with misinformation we're going to see
more significant regulation of marijuana
than we do of cigarettes which are sold
everywhere licensed dispensaries you
have to be 21 plus obviously to be in
there there's zero evidence that
recreational marijuana has had any
effect on the rate of fatal car crashes
in Colorado where in fact fatal car
accidents fell during the first year
that recreational marijuana was publicly
and legally available clearly the
alcohol industry is very scared of
profits dropping but what is implicit in
that fear is that if people can legally
smoke pot they will link drink less
alcohol and the reality is that if at
least some of the people who regularly
get drunk we're instead smoking pot we
wouldn't see accidents car accidents
eliminated but you would see a decrease
in the number of fatal car accidents
that is absolutely undeniable the
alcohol industry is in a tizzy over this
and we need to do everything we can to
not allow this type of disinformation
propaganda to influence voters because
it is nothing more than complete and
utter nonsense